bonsoir le 7 8 en direct entre 18 et 19
heures une heure pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale première invitée ce
soir alain jaj bon soir soit vous êtes
le maire de la verrière en poste depuis
le mois d'avril de cette année suite au
départ de pierre c'est lincourt vous ne
manquez pas de projet on va en parler
durant les prochaines minutes auparavant
depuis six mois maintenant vous êtes
installés est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment d' imposer votre rythme de
vous faire entendre et d'avoir pris
pleinement vos fonctions n'a pas
beaucoup de temps pour cela
quand on est maire tout de suite
opération tout de suite opérationnels en
plus on est en cours de mandat il ya des
projets il ya de l'activité il ya des
attentes il ya des attentes à tous
niveaux donc non le rythme est déjà pris
bien évidemment on parlera des projets
de cette commune de la verrière au cours
de la première partie de ce cette suite
valérie auribeau bonsoir ça nous sommes
mardi le mardi c'est la chronique
environnement dans une vingtaine de
minutes oui absolument et ce soir nous
parlerons de la reconquête de la faune
et la reconquête des villes par la faune
et la flore à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette politique verte est impulsée par
bouygues construction et ce soit pour
nous en parler un écologue de cette
entreprise olivier lemoine un écologue
et on lui demandera première question ce
qu'est un écologue si vous voulez le
savoir restez avec nous pour la
chronique environnement avec valérie
dans une vingtaine de minutes avant de
découvrir les images les titres en
images de ce 30 octobre un mot sur
l'ouragan 110 qui a frappé la côte est
des états unis
nous avons en ligne sandrine clavel
bonsoir bonsoir sandrine clavel vous
êtes doyen de la faculté de droit de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines et vous êtes à new york
depuis quelques jours comment avez vous
vécu cette nuit il est environ 13 heures
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
suivent en direct il est 18 heures en
france 13 heures à peu près du côté de
new york et vous avez vécu cette nuit
avec le passage de l'ouragan
je suis très bien ici là la ville en
fête est un peu coupé en deux le nord le
nord de la côte d'or de la promenade des
rues les chauffeurs à peu près normale
et puis au fil de la promenade elle
brûla fait beaucoup plus compliqué mais
moi je suis au nord de la 39e et donc
énormément de choses il ya quelques
il ya quand même quelques grues qui fait
fondre à des arbres en travers de la rue
il ya tout de même eu l'état de
catastrophe majeure qui a été déclarée
par le président dans cet état de new
york et malgré tout vous semblez restés
assez calmes
vous êtes resté chez vous toute la nuit
à suivre ces informations est ce qu'il y
a eu des coupures de courant aussi par
exemple c'est ce qu'on a pu suivre un
petit peu depuis la france les coupures
de courant
tout à fait voilà les coupures de
courant fli fait l'application que je
voulais que je vous décrivais c'est à
dire que moi je vais j'en ai absolument
pas suivi tout fonctionnait bien
par contre je me suis baladé ce matin je
suis descendu jusqu'à la 15e rue et là
par contre à vous à partir d'accra 9e
rue il ya plus en plus du tout
d'électricité
il ya des camions de connaître la
compagnie d'électricité partout ils
savent pas très bien quand ils pourront
rétablir le courant et ce matin
j'entendais des gens qui disaient que ça
pourrait prendre jusqu'à dix jours dans
certaines zones pour rétablir le courant
est ce que la vie reprend est ce que les
new yorkaises sortent aussi dans les
rues au delà de la 39e rue que ce soit
au nord ou au sud est ce qu'il ya une
musique qui reprend oui quitte à coeur
ce matin à 10 heures à les rues étaient
désertes moi j'avais vu les villes
milliards can pas par là je veux bien je
suis dans un taxi est magnifique mais
les gens sont reçus les cheveux patriat
dessins de dégagement cre il faut dire
qu'il ya beaucoup d'heureux détritus
sont barrées parce qu'il ya des risques
d'effondrement des chaufferettes à et
donc ça complique évidemment un petit
peu la circulation
l'école n'y a aucun métro aucun but sauf
que le moyen préféré les gens qui ont
besoin peut dépasser ont été obligés de
prendre leur voiture
est-ce que ça va retarder aussi votre
retour en france parce que pour
l'instant il n'ya plus d'avions possible
n'était plus possible de prendre l'avion
merci sony clavel d'avoir été avec nous
effectivement liaison un petit peu
difficile
merci pour ce témoignage en tout cas
donc de sandrine clavel doyen de la
faculté de droit de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines et
qui se trouvait et qui se trouve
toujours à new york après ce passage de
l'ouragan
on revient dans les yvelines à présent
pour un point en images sur quelques-uns
des sujets que nous allons aborder ce 30
octobre
enquête d'ufc que choisir révèle qu'en
matière de médecine le département des
yvelines n'échappe ni aux déserts
médicaux et demi aux dépassements
d'honoraires
nous ferons le point à quelques jours de
la toussaint nous avons voulu en savoir
plus sur le marché des pompes funèbres
un développement at a noté celui de la
crémation
elle s'appelle manon altazin elle a 22
ans elle est élève pilote à l'aérodrome
des mureaux sa particularité la jeune
femme est sourde nous l'avons rencontré
à l'occasion d'une opération de
solidarité proposé par l'association fly
and keys c'était ce samedi à saint cyr
l'école et des responsables de cette
association viendront aussi sur le
plateau tout à l'heure l aventure des
goncourt du délit c'est en se poursuivre
pour les élèves du lycée jean vilar de
plaisir dernière ligne droite avant de
rendre leur copie ce sera le 4 novembre
et le goncourt des lycéens sera décerné
le 15 novembre
ufc que choisir a donc enquêté sur ces
fameux déserts médicaux bien que cela
puisse paraître surprenant notre
département n'est pas épargné reportage
catherine plateau et guillaume cambis
les ivy n'est pas un département
protéger pas que je sache manque de
médecins dépassements d'honoraires
l'association ufc que choisir tire la
sonnette d'alarmé récent rapport dresse
une carte de la fracture sanitaire en
france et le département n'est pas
épargné notamment par les déserts
médicaux
même sur saint quentin en yvelines les
chiffres sont éloquents en ce qui
concerne le nombre de médecins
généralistes sur l'agglomération
le ratio est de 29,3 médecins à manille
alors qu'il est de 70 à trappes et ufc
que choisir s'est aussi intéressé à
trois spécialités dites en accès libre
l'ophtalmologie la pédiatrie et la
gynécologie
il manque des gynécologues sur les
yvelines comme
dans beaucoup d'endroits ils dépassent
les honoraires au n'ouvre plus à
clientèle dans le département les
dépassements d'honoraires concernent
surtout le sud des yvelines des secteurs
comme chevreuse ou rambouillet un accord
national décrit comme historique a été
trouvé le 23 octobre le seuil de
dépassement est limité à 150 %
ufc que choisir souhaiterait plafonner
ce dépassement à 40%
une moyenne nationale prise en compte
par les mutuelles et professionnels du
gouvernement sont passés à 150 % avec
diminution possible sur trois ans or on
sait très bien que connaissant l'esprit
français que ça ne se fera pas et ça
risque d'inciter au contraire les
professionnels de santé à rechercher les
secteurs bien dotées déjà et de prendre
des dépassements encore plus faramineux
entre les médecins qui désertent
certains quartiers et les dépassements
d'honoraires
l'association de consommateurs préconise
des aides spécifiques pour permettre aux
médecins de s'installer dans des zones
identifiées et de limiter les
implantations dans des zones dites
surdotées